okay good morning everyone so we're
going to enter the last phase of the
class now we have about 8 lectures left
in fact I guess I should tell you a
little bit about the timeline so I will
be away at a conference next Monday no
not next Monday the Monday of
Thanksgiving week there will be no
classes no Monday and a Wednesday okay
so that entire week is completely free
so we'll have the rest of this week and
next week and then we'll have the week
that we get back after Thanksgiving
holiday okay so that's eight more
lectures and originally I thought about
having a unit on linear algebra and then
a unit on vector calculus but I think
that that's a little bit redundant so
I'm going to try to combine the two
because really linear algebra and vector
calculus have a lot in common okay so
I'm going to kind of interweave these
two topics together today we're going to
be doing an overview of vectors so just
kind of vector spaces so mostly we're
thinking about vectors in 3d so this is
going to include things like inner
product and the norm of a vector and the
cross product of a vector and so most
I'm assuming that most of what I'm going
to talk about today is review for most
of you but I think it's still good to
kind of refresh everybody on the
notation that I'm using and just
remember kind of exactly what's vectors
and inner products and norms and all of
these things are because in the next two
lectures we're going to start
introducing the idea of what a vector
space is more generally so you know
we're talking about physical vectors in
3d and 3-space but most of these ideas
generalize to vectors in an arbitrary n
dimensional space like
state vectors we used for our ordinary
differential equations okay
so we've already been looking at linear
algebra a little bit in the context of
differential equations we looked at
heigen values and eigenvectors and
coordinate systems and determinants and
here we're going to revisit them in a
little bit more of a canonical way in
the framework of linear algebra so we're
gonna start talking about vector spaces
but we're also going to introduce the
concepts of differential operators okay
like the gradient the divergence and the
curl objects which are essentially
related to inner products and cross
products of vectors in 3d okay so this
is going to serve as the foundation for
vector spaces and then the work we do in
vector calculus with div grad and Carl
okay and all of you have seen diff grad
and Crowell I'm assuming but maybe it's
been a little while for some of you okay
so we're gonna start off pretty you know
at the basic foundational level so we're
just going to talk about vectors to
start okay so we're going to consider a
three dimensional space and we all like
three space because we feel like we live
in three space I say we feel like it
because those are the directions that we
you know walk around and move and
pinpoint physical objects but there's
also dimensions of time and other
dimensions so it's always hard for me to
draw a right-handed coordinate system
because I'm left-handed and everything
in my body tells me that I should draw
this the other way but I'll try very
very hard to draw a proper right-handed
coordinate system so if you have x and y
and you rotate your hand in the
direction X goes into Y then Z should
pop out the direction your thumbs
pointing how many of you are
left-handers just curious okay a few not
not many Wow two three okay
once I lived in a house with ten people
and four of us we're left-handed which
is strange okay so we have a
three-dimensional space given by these
coordinate directions XY and Z and we're
going to introduce the idea of a unit
vector in the X the Y and the Z
direction because we're going to use
this notation a lot and the the things
that follow so before before a vector
was X bar under bar was a vector but now
I'm going to write X with an arrow on
top as a vector and part of the reason
for doing this is that I really want to
indicate that these are physical pointer
type vectors they're really pointing to
a physical location and XYZ coordinates
okay and it also looks a little bit
better with the math later on so we're
going to define these unit vectors in
the x y&z directions and we're going to
call them I J and K okay and these are
really vectors X as a I as a vector J as
vector and K is a vector and they each
have unit length and they're only
aligned in one of the coordinate
directions okay
so I J and K are unit vectors meaning
that they have unit links okay and we've
talked about this a little bit before
but the I J and K directions form an
orthonormal basis for this
three-dimensional vector space okay so
these form an orthonormal basis
so what's the difference between
orthonormal and orthogonal yeah so
orthonormal means that they're all
normalized to have unit length
I could have orthogonal vectors to i3j
and 14k those it certainly be an
orthogonal set of vectors but if they
have unit length than they're
orthonormal they're normalized okay and
the basis just means that every possible
direction in my vector space can be
written as a linear combination of these
primal basis vectors so we'll talk a
little bit more about what a basis means
formally when we get to vector spaces
and that'll be a little bit later in the
next couple lectures okay sometimes we
call this 3d space a Euclidean space
because all of the coordinate directions
are straight and the space is the same
no matter where I put the origin no
matter where i zoom in this space
basically has the same flat XY and z
directions there are lots of spaces that
are curved like if you write down the
gravitational potential of a you know
heavy planet or a neutron star or
something it actually bends space around
it so the equations of motion would be
written in a curved space but we're
talking about nice simple flat
coordinate systems called euclidean
spaces okay so if I was on the surface
of a sphere like the earth if I was on a
big flat field then it would look
locally like a Euclidean space because
it's locally flat even though if i zoom
zoom way out we would see that the
surface is actually curved and is not
that euclidean okay so I'm going to go
through the basics we're going to go
through vector addition vector
subtraction and then we're going to get
to the dot product and cross product
okay
so in my XY and Z spaces I can have my
vector a and B and I'm sure all of you
know that to add a and B we essentially
just tack a onto the end of B or vice
versa we could tack B onto the end of a
and we get this vector a plus B ok
pretty straightforward and you can write
this like so I haven't actually told you
what a is let's say a is some component
a I a 1 in the ice direction plus a 2 in
the J direction plus a 3 in the K
direction okay so we can write any
vector I told you that I J and K formed
orthogonal basis and so I can write any
vector a as some linear combination some
you know constants times I J and K added
together every vector can be written
this way B is gonna be the same thing be
1 I plus B 2 J plus B 3 ok and so a plus
B if I have a 1 in the X direction and B
1 in the X direction and I add them
together I just get a 1 plus B 1 in the
X Direction plus a2 plus b2 in the J
direction plus a 3 plus B 3 in the K
direction ok if I subtract these vectors
so I have a and B if I subtract these
vectors then I essentially am looking
for the vector that would take me from
one point to the other
so this is B minus a and the way we can
figure out kind of what direction this
arrow points and really justify why it's
pointing in this direction is because if
I added a to B minus a I should end up
with B okay so if I add a plus B minus a
it has to take me to this direction B
okay okay good so we're gonna pick up a
little steam so we always before have
written vectors as column vectors right
little n by one or three by one matrices
okay so we can write vectors as three by
one matrices and this is what we've
always done in the past so we can say
that a is equal to a 1 a 2 a 3 B is
equal to B 1 B 2 B 3 I J and K are super
easy right I it's just 1 0 0 J is 0 1 0
and K is 0 0 1 ok so what we're talking
about here is a way of representing a
direction in space okay
maybe B minus ay ay plus B these are all
directions in a three-dimensional space
they all point to some object okay and
this is one way that we can represent
that information is in a column vector
okay good
so now we're gonna talk about inner
products and inner products they're
gonna be extremely useful so the reason
I'm starting off really really slow
today is because the basic ideas of
inner products and cross products and
vectors these completely generalize to
higher dimensional vectors and so in the
next part of this class in me5 65 we're
going to be talking about how to solve
partial differential equations Fourier
transforms the plas transforms things
like that and all of those ideas
naturally live in a big high dimensional
vector space okay that means a vector
space where your vector is really really
really tall with a lot of entries in it
okay and things like inner products
generalize they don't just apply to
vectors they also apply to things like
functions I can tell you how close two
functions are to each other by looking
at the inner product of those functions
okay so I really want to start building
this up simply so that we're really
really comfortable with these ideas
because we're gonna bend them to the
limits of their definitions so I want
you to know what the limits of those
definitions are okay so for an inner
product there's a lot of different ways
to write this everyone has their own
favorite way I'll just tell you all
three of the kind of common ones so we
usually write a dot product sorry an
inner product with a dot and sometimes
we call it a dot product because your
dotting these together so dots can be a
vector sorry a verb of what you do to
two vectors if you take their inner
product so a dot B is just a 1 B 1 plus
a 2 B 2 plus a 3 B 3 and notice that
this is just a number I took two vectors
I dotted them together I get a number
okay so this is a scaler it's not a
vector another way to write this is you
can say a paired with be using
funky brackets okay this is the dirac
this was invented by Dirac for quantum
mechanics and he was using functions and
kind of generalizing beside you have an
inner product so this is a Dirac bra ket
notation so this is a bra and this is a
ket and they form a bracket pretty
clever and you can put stuff inside
there too so another thing we can do if
we choose to write our vectors as column
vectors which is what I kind of prefer
to think about I always think of vectors
is being column vectors in my mind then
I have a transpose B that's also a way
of writing the inner product right if I
take a transpose now it's this row
vector times B 1 B 2 B 3 my column
vector and if I multiply this matrix by
this matrix I get the sum of all those
pairs which is just a number okay so
these are three different ways of
writing the inner product I'm totally
fine with any of them usually I'm gonna
write it this way because this is kind
of the most common if we ever
programming it in the computer I would
write it this way and if we were doing
quantum mechanics we'd write it this way
okay okay good so inner products are
super super useful because they allow us
to do lots of things that we want to do
to physical objects they allow us to
measure the lengths of a vector so there
is an induced length for all vectors
given by this inner product it also
allows you to take two vectors and
project one into the direction of the
other one okay so those are the two
things we're going to look at that are
kind of the number one and number two
most important uses of an inner product
okay so let's do that
and of course we didn't have to use the
I J and K directions we could have
introduced cylindrical coordinates or
spherical coordinates which at some
point we will do but for now we're gonna
use these nice Cartesian Euclidian
coordinates okay because because they're
nice and Euclidian okay so from the
Pythagorean theorem we know that the
length of a is equal to the square root
of a 1 squared plus a 2 squared plus a 3
squared okay I just take the sum of the
squares of all the components I take the
square root I can do this because a 1 a
2 and a 3 point in different directions
they're in the I the J in the K
direction and because they're completely
orthogonal if I J and K we're not
orthogonal then this would not be the
length this completely rests on the fact
that I J and K are orthogonal to each
other or else the Pythagorean theorem
would not hold because you need right
triangles right and so we call this
length we have a special symbol for it
in math which is double left bars double
right bars okay this is kind of like the
absolute value of a but it's a stronger
absolute value because this is for a
vector not just a scalar so this kind of
absolute value of my vector is called a
norm and it's exactly equal to this
quantity which is the same as a dotted
with a square root all right if I took a
dot with a I would have a 1 a 1 plus a 2
a 2 plus a 3 a 3 all right a 1 squared
plus a 2 squared plus B 3 squared to the
one-half power okay
so we can always define a norm by using
the inner product of those vectors okay
and this norm tells me how long this
vector a is write a short vector a will
have a small norm a long vector a will
have a long norm if I have two vectors a
and B and I want to know how far apart
they point then I would take the norm of
a minus B and that tells me how far
apart these two vectors are pointing the
distance between a and B now I can
generalize this notion of an inner
product and we're going to do that so
that instead of just working on three
vectors we can work on really really
really huge vectors or we can even work
on general infinite dimensional vector
spaces like the space of all polynomial
functions
okay so later we're gonna find that the
space of polynomials satisfies the
definition of a vector space which I
haven't told you about yet and so it's
possible to define an inner product and
it's also possible to say what is the
length what's the distance between two
polynomials or two functions all right
to Taylor series expansions so this idea
of a norm is way way more general than
just three vectors but it has a super
simple interpretation in the case of
three vectors it's just the length of
that vector and it's the inner product
to the half power okay any questions at
this points no this is pretty much all
review okay so one thing we can do
that's kind of a common thing is I can
take a vector that does not have unit
length and I can make it into a vector
with unit length so I can normalize it's
a nice funny word so the reason we call
this a norm is because we it's the
length and we can use it to normalize a
vector
so I can normalize a vector a by just
saying a divided by the length of a okay
and now this is a unit vector or a
vector with unit norm with norm equal to
one so norm means length unit length
means it's a unit vector so I normalize
a by dividing by its length this makes
sense okay if you took the norm of this
it would have norm one okay good okay so
this is kind of the algebraic definition
of inner product right I took a vector a
which was a column vector and I
multiplied it by its transpose and we
got a length so now we're going to talk
a little bit about the geometry of what
an inner product means and so this is
really a measure of orthogonality so the
inner product will tell me how close or
how far from orthogonal are two vectors
okay which is a really really really
important concept so if I'm going to
create a basis for some vector space I
had better be able to tell if my vectors
orthogonal or not okay so the way we're
going to do this is we're going to
construct two vectors again
okay so we're gonna have our two vectors
a and B and these two vectors have some
angle between them okay there's some
angle between these vectors and we're
going to essentially be able to write
the dot product of a and B in terms of
the length of a the length of B and this
angle theta so we can say a dot B is
equal to I think it's got to be the
length of a time's the length of B and
it's got to be times cosine of theta
because we know so I'm acting like you
don't know anything about inner products
but really you know a lot about inner
products you know that if a and B are
pointing in the same direction then
that's the way that you get the biggest
inner product right and if a and B are
completely orthogonal then they would
have zero inner product this is a fact
that we know if a and B are orthogonal
they have zero inner product if a and B
point in the same direction they have
kind of the maximal inner product and so
I have the length of a time's the length
of B times cosine of theta
when this theta is 0 its 1 and when
theta is 90 degrees when they're
completely perpendicular this dot
product is zero okay so if parallel then
a dot B is just the length of a time's
the length of B and if perpendicular
then the dot product is zero okay so
that's kind of a nice geometric
interpretation of what the dot products
doing you could prove this formula is
true by using the law of cosines from
trigonometry which I don't remember but
I do remember this because this one
actually
sense physically what else okay so
they're really really really important
property of inner products aside from
the fact that you can define a length
there's a second super important
property of inner products and it's that
you can use the inner product to take a
vector and project it into the direction
of another vector
okay so vector projection is probably
the most it's at least one of the two
most important properties of the inner
product is that you can you can define
vector projections and we're also going
to use this a ton in M II 565 so I'll
tell you what it looks like first and
then I'll tell you how we're gonna use
it okay so let's say how do I do this
we're going to project a in the
direction of B so I have some little B
vector here for now let's assume that B
has unit length so assume that the norm
of B equals 1 okay unit length and we're
gonna have some a vector then oftentimes
what I want to do is I want to project a
into the B direction so I'm going to
write this out because the English is
important so we're going to project a
into the B direction so especially if B
has unit length I think of it as a
direction all unit vectors point in a
direction and they uniquely define that
direction okay so what I want to know is
how much of a is in the B direction so
what I really want to know is in the B
direction
what is the projection of a onto this B
direction how long is this projected
black dashed vector okay so this dashed
black vector the length of it said the
lengths of my - black vector is equal to
a dot B okay the dot product of a with B
is the length of this - black vector
it's how much of a is in that unit B
direction and then if I actually want to
represent this dashed black line as a
vector I would say a dot B this is just
a number it's just a length times B this
is a vector pointing in the B direction
it has length a dot B and so it has the
length of how much of a is in that B
direction okay how many of you like me
to say this again that makes sense yeah
okay good so this is a projected onto B
yeah
was it no expression yes OB didn't good
you read my mind
if B is not equal to one then you need a
dotted with B in the B direction divided
by the norm of B squared because I pick
up a length here and here because I have
two factors of the length of B in the
numerator so I need to cancel out two
factors of the length in the denominator
yeah so this is kind of the generic
projection good yeah yeah so if I have
some direction B and I want to know and
I have some vector a and I want to know
how much of a is pointing in the B
direction so I want to decompose a into
some B part and then some other parts I
take the dot product of a and B and that
tells me the length of how much of a is
in that B direction as long as B is a
unit vector yeah yeah because you get a
norm of B from here and a normal B from
here okay good okay I have time to tell
you about two super useful inequalities
so I'm gonna have some of this on the
homework because I don't think I have
time to kind of go through all of the
neat identities about dot products and
vector products and all this in class so
I'm going to tell you what some of these
things are and I'm gonna ask you to
verify some of them on the homework okay
so there's something called the Cauchy
Schwarz inequality anytime you see Koshi
it's a big deal and Schwarz less of a
big deal
okay so the Koshi Schwarz inequality
says for any two vectors we have the
following identity so a dotted with B is
just a number right it's a scalar number
and so I can take its absolute value so
the the magnitude of the this dot
product is always less than or equal to
the length of a time's the length of B
kind of an obvious inequality actually
right because this dot product is equal
to this times cos theta so it has to be
less than or equal to one this is
exactly equal if these are pointing in
the same direction or if one of them is
equal to zero okay uneven more useful
identity is called the triangle
inequality and the triangle inequality
is used it's one of the most used
theorems and all of math and it's not
just used to prove things it's useful to
give us kind of a geometric intuition
about how vectors work okay so this
triangle inequality says that the norm
of a plus B is always less than or equal
to the norm of a plus the norm of B this
has a super simple geometric
interpretation I have some a and I have
some beef and so we know that the vector
a plus B is something like here right
now this vector can only be equal to the
sum of these lengths when a and B point
in exactly the same direction because
they're adding in the same direction
any time a and B don't point in the same
direction part of a is cancelling some
part of B okay there's like this or
direction where a is positive and B is
negative and they're canceling so some
part of a and B are being canceled out
and so this length a plus B is always
less than or equal to a length of a plus
length of B and they're only equal when
a and B point in exactly the same
direction it's that simple if you want
to see the proof it's in my notes but I
don't really want to write it down it's
kind of boring but it's also really
really useful and it uses the Koshi
Schwarz inequality which is probably why
people gave it a name any questions
about inner products
okay that's all I want to say about
inner products for now inner products
are going to come back in a big way when
we talk about vector spaces they're one
of the defining properties of a vector
spaces that you can define an inner
product so you can define the length
between two vectors or the length of a
vector and it's an idea that generalizes
way way beyond three vectors okay so
we're going to use it to define the
length between functions and these
functions might be the solutions to
partial differential equations in a
infinite dimensional function space
called a Hilbert space but don't worry
we're gonna do that next quarter after
Christmas so it's so far away we don't
have to think about it okay so now we're
going to talk about the cross product
the cross product is cool because it
also has a great geometric
interpretation okay all of these things
are they're vectors right there
fundamentally geometric objects so we
still have our two vectors a a 1 I plus
a 2 J plus a 3 K and we have B equals B
1 shouldn't have erased it plus B 2 J
plus B 3 ok the cross product how many
of you have like know how to compute the
cross product right now if I give you
two vectors you've compute the cross
product right and what would you use
MATLAB ok good so see this is actually I
don't remember how to do this in MATLAB
I'm assuming there's a cross command but
I don't know so the way that we all
learn how to do this in school is using
the determinant of a matrix that we
construct right okay so the cross
product is given by this cross a cross B
and we say a cross B is equal to the
determinant of a very special matrix
given by i j k
a 1 a 2 a 3 B 1 B 2 B 3 now as far as
I'm concerned this is a pretty dangerous
notation because I J and K are not
numbers and so acting like their numbers
in the matrix is pretty dodgy but this
is a nice way to remember the
cross-product formula and it actually is
kind of amazing remember I told you that
the geometric interpretation of the
determinant is the volume of the span of
these vectors either the row or the
column vectors that same interpretation
applies for this cross-product which is
kind of amazing so this determinant
really does have a geometric meaning
even though we're plugging in weird
vectors in a matrix and it doesn't make
sense okay so the way you take this
determinant I'm just going to write it
out in long form one time is you take I
times this 2 by 2 determinants ok so
it's I times the determinant of a2 a3 b2
b3 not plus J minus J times the
determinant of these this 2 by 2 which
is a1 a3 b1 b3 plus K times the
determinant of a1 a2 b1 b2 okay and you
could take these determinants and you
get a2 b3 minus a3 b2 a1 b3 minus a3 b1
that's a thought right you can take
these determines and you get some funky
expression in terms of all of these A's
and B's but notice this is a vector the
cross product is fundamentally a vector
not a scalar which is interesting it's
somehow different fundamentally than the
inner product the inner product takes
two vectors gives me a number cross
product takes two vectors gives me a
vector now it's interesting that this a
cross B vector is perpendicular to both
a and B
okay how would I verify that so this is
a homework problem how would I verify
that a cross B is perpendicular to both
a and B dot product of this with a and
then the dot product of this with B okay
I'm going to write this out long form
because I'm going to use it later so
this equals a2 b3 minus a3 b2 I minus a1
b3 minus a3 b1 J plus a1 b2 minus a2 b1
okay okay so you would take this vector
and you would dot it with a you know
this times a 1 plus this times a 2 plus
this times a 3 and you're gonna find
that all of this stuff just magically
cancels out this vector is perpendicular
to both a and B not only are they
perpendicular but they also follow a
right-hand rule so if I have a and B
then a cross B points perpendicular
following the right-hand rule
now this isn't some magic way of the
universe telling me that I'm
fundamentally wrong this is just how we
define the cross product okay if we
wanted to define it left hand I would
just flip DNA no problem okay so
left-handed does mean sinister right the
Latin word for left-handed is sin us
from sin us I don't know what it is it's
basically sinister which I've always
appreciated okay now a couple other
things yes so that's going to be a
homework problem okay good
almost done so the idea here of this
cross product if we're gonna think about
it geometrically again we have x y&z and
we have our vectors which was really
badly we have our vectors a and B so the
length of my cross product the magnitude
or the norm of my cross product is equal
to the area of this parallelogram which
is starting to seem very reminiscent of
what we learned about determinants
earlier right I'm taking the determinant
of something where one row is a one rows
B and the other row is ijk and it turns
out that the norm of my cross product
this thing
a cross B has a length so it's
perpendicular to both a and B and it's
length is equal to this area here the
area of this parallelogram between a and
B you could prove this it is in the
lecture notes the basic idea is that if
I take a and B then they have some angle
theta between them and this height here
is equal to the norm of B times sine
theta and so the area of this
parallelogram is norm of a kind of the
base times the height which is norm of B
sine theta now I didn't prove that this
is what the cross products equal to but
you can take the cross product and take
the norm of this nasty vector expression
and you can show and I do in the notes
that it's equal to this area of the
parallelogram spanned by a and B okay so
if a and B are nearly nearly nearly
parallel then this parallelogram has
almost no area and my cross-product is
super short but if a and B are
perpendicular then this parallelogram is
going to have the maximal possible area
and a cross B is going to be as long as
possible okay so the length of a cross B
depends on how orthogonal a and B are
okay so this is starting to look very
reminiscent of the dot product right the
dot product was length of a length of B
cos theta this is equal to the length of
a cross B okay any questions so far okay
one last thing and this is one of my
favorite things about the cross product
is that there's a really really nice way
of writing it as a matrix so how many of
you have seen a cross product written in
terms of a matrix multiplication before
okay even in a really dry lecture I like
to have at least one thing you haven't
seen before so we have this expression
for a cross B equals all of this stuff
right and so I can take that and I can
write it I'm gonna get rid of everything
but the bottom row okay this is a cross
B on the bottom so what I can do is if I
write B as a column vector b1 b2 b3 then
there is some matrix that will give me a
cross when multiplied by B okay there's
some matrix that when I multiply it by a
column vector B it does exactly the same
thing
as a Crosby okay so how do we do it so
what we're reading out here we're going
to get a vector out which is a cross B
and this thing's going to have an i a J
and a K component right a cross B is a
vector so it has an AI component a J
component and then K component so what
is my I component of the cross product a
to b3 minus a3 b2
okay so a3 b3 - did I mess up a - b3
minus a3 b2 what's a zero okay so this
row when I multiply it by B gives me
this ice term at my cross product okay
what about my J term how do I get my J
term well I have a - a - minus a plus a3
b1
so plus a3 b1 I have no B choose and I
have a minus a1 b3 and then the last row
I can read it out as minus a2 a1 0 so
this matrix is the a cross matrix this
is a matrix that does the same thing as
a cross and it's just waiting for a
vector to multiply it so a cross is a
matrix just waiting for a vector to take
the cross product with okay this is a
really special type of matrix it's
called skew symmetric because it's
symmetric about the axis about the
diagonal except that all of the terms
are - of each other so this is called
skew symmetric it's a really special
type of matrix this is going to be
particularly useful when we start
thinking about things like the curl
del cross okay so if a was a vector
partial partial X partial partial Y
partial partial Z let's say this is a
cross I can write the curl as a matrix
of partial derivatives partial partial Z
partial partial Y minus partial partial
X and so on and so forth so I can write
a matrix that will do the curl for me
okay okay that's all I want to say today
soon either next time or on Monday we're
going to talk about vector spaces and in
the other lecture we're going to talk
about div grad and curl we're gonna
start using vectors of differential
operators okay okay thank you